talking of the voice how long  before you developed the voice or did  you find it pretty quickly uh i started  in the voice six months before we  started filming and then i stayed in it  while we were filming of course which  was really super fun for adam  [Music]  i made him deal with that every [ __ ]  day  uh but you know i'm still doing it  but it actually for me i don't know for  what it's worth ridley shoots fast and  he's got four cameras going  once at any given time if not more so i  thought it was harder to go in and out  of character i thought it was actually  easier to stay in character on set so i  i wish not to sensationalize this thing  but i do wish to uh express gratitude to  my fellow actor that i was on stage with  every day  no okay  [Music]